bonjour frédéric lecocq merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
avec la non-signature justement quel est
le message que la cgt souhaite envoyer à
la direction d'un dp bonjour tout
d'abord la cgt envoie un message à
l'appel des salariés également ne sont
pas satisfaits des mesures en même s'il
ya eu des mesures proposées par la
direction
ce n'est pas à la hauteur
l'ensemble obtenir alors des pas à la
hauteur de ce que les salariés
souhaitent obtenir justement qu'est-ce
que les salariés elle souhaite obtenir
le contexte social et économique pour
reprendre avant de répondre directement
votre question c'est que ça fait 15 mois
que les salariés vécu à l'activité
partielle qui a été payé par le
gouvernement et non l'entreprise un
accord de rupture conventionnelle active
qui prévoit faire partir 1150 personnes
avant la fin de l'année et qu'il a
rapporté en moyenne 40 millions
d'économies en l'état ensuite il ya le
fait que l'entreprise a investi 1
milliard 6 dans des aéroports à
l'étranger et malgré tout c'est déjà
toutes ses contraintes et ses baisses de
salaire déjà des baisses de salaires
dans l'activité partielle certains fils
khamis 100 euros l'entreprise doit
continuer à faire payer un tribut qui
est trop lourd pour les salariés nous on
était on était partis au départ sur le
retrait du parc pour voir ce que la
direction va fermer sept à ses tissus
mais en tout cas 5% pendant trois ans cc
c'est pas suffisant pour les salariés
les salariés avaient pu se contenter par
exemple de 2 % sur deux ans mais là il
ya une bonne partie est salarié qui
refuse donc la cgt toujours au
rendez-vous et matière sont très vite
alors est ce que vous pensez également
qui va être encore possible dans l'est
dans les semaines à venir pour pour
négocier justement avec la direction de
la dp
écoutez on verra déjà demain on verra en
fonction de la mobilisation qui sera
présente sur l'aéroport à partir de 7
heures et puis et bien ensuite prendre à
un petit peu de recul avec ce qui se
sera passé hier et on réfléchira là à la
suite desquelles projection vous faites
justement là des des jours d des
semaines à venir vous l'avez dit une une
mobilisation demain et après en fait ça
va dépendre aussi de la mobilisation qui
aura lieu demain
je pense qu'il ya un certain sens et
collègues salariés
ils ne sont pas satisfaits de ce qui a
été proposé par la direction
donc si demain ils sont nombreux pour
montrer leur mécontentement et bien en
se voir ensemble on réfléchira pour la
suite les semaines à venir
est ce que est ce que ça sera possible
pas possible et puis de toute manière il
ya eu donc sociale qui va s'annoncer
certainement très compliqué d
réorganisation totale de l'entreprise
sont prévues à la fin de l'année en
début d'année prochaine
voilà ça va être aussi tout pattaya
manic allemand s'est beaucoup frédéric
lecocq d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
assuré arte france rappelle que vous
êtes délégué syndical cgt chez adp merci
beaucoup